etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ganz gut sagt auch ich hab
das jetzt schon abgedreht und wollten
auch zwei drei sachen dazu sagen erst
mal ja ich weiß das kam jetzt in den
letzten vier wochen oder fünf wochen
drei amazonen retouren videos was dann
schon ein bisschen vieles drei monate
was zu machen finde ich auf jeden fall
in ordnung und das wird auch so weiter
gehen das war jetzt ein bisschen viel
aber ich hatte noch ein paket und ich
wollte das unbedingt aufmachen und ist
ja auch dumm wenn ich das video dann
nicht hochladen zweite sache bevor die
stadt es wird glaube ich ganz
interessant weil das weißt du das erste
paket wo ich erst sagte chamisa flop und
dann wurde es doch überrascht gut und
dritte sache ich habe jetzt gesehen dass
ich manchmal läuft darüber beschweren
dass sich die preise zu hoch ansetze
also ich schaue einfach in meinem
internet ich habe ja so eine app und
dann werden wir direkt die preise
angeschaut und klar sind das immer
relativ hohe preise aber ich gehe
natürlich nicht davon aus dass ich falls
ich die sachen wirklich weiter verkaufen
das dafür bekomme also das ist völliger
quatsch beispiel vorletztes amazon video
da hatten wir glaube ich drogerie
retouren im wert von über 5000 euro und
am ende habe ich mit dem ding ich habe
glaube ich 80 euro bezahlt und habe 400
euro verlust gemacht also ich hab davon
fast gar nichts verkauft da war halt
auch wirklich die hälfte der produkte
defekt also für die die es interessiert
das ist dann auch oft sohn dann aber ich
würde sagen auf geht's viel spaß leute
was geht wo soll ich anfangen ich muss
das ganze jetzt wirklich im sitzen
machen ich war acht tage auf mallorca
wenn jetzt schon relativ krank geworden
dann doch es ist kein chor oder aber
naja das youtube geschäft muss irgendwie
weitergehen und ich habe echt noch viel
was ich so abdrehen möchte die so
nächste woche deswegen direkt mal rein
mit dem nächsten amazon paket von
notfalls ihr das letzte wieder noch
nicht gesehen hat dazu das war
eigentlich echt sehr solide check das
super gerne mal ab wir haben hier jetzt
noch ein weiteres paket das steht hier
auch schon bereit
wo ich wirklich noch eine woche urlaub
von dem urlaub mindestens ok alex fall
nicht um so anstrengen jetzt auch nicht
zweites paket es ist wirklich unfassbar
schwer wenn ich das denn jetzt ihr euch
ob die kamera positionieren wir lassen
uns einfach mal so dass sie gut aus vor
alter also der urlaub hat mich echt mehr
mitgenommen als nicht angenommen aber
das gute ist ich habe letzten von emma
eine neue matratze und ein geiles
kopfkissen zugeschickt bekommen und die
beiden sachen in kombination sind
einfach nur ein traum deswegen vielen
dank dafür das schauen wir uns bei eben
an wo ich denn so aktuell mächtige und
warum das so geil ist okay das hat sich
jetzt auch ein bisschen falsch angehört
ich befinde mich gerade in meinem
schlafzimmer und emma war es ganz ganz
wichtig dass sich die matratze so
authentisch wie möglich vorstelle und
deswegen dachte ich mir machen wir das
jetzt auch mal authentisch wir haben
jetzt gerade halb zwölf und ich schaue
schon dass ich meistens wirklich sofort
12 im bett bin klappt nicht immer wie
heute klappt es sollte ich darf jetzt
mittlerweile schon seit über drei wochen
auf dieser matratze schlafen ich hatte
vorher ziemlich lange anderen dachte
wieso eigentlich brauche ich gar keine
neue matratze mittlerweile bin ich davon
überzeugt dieses ding ist wirklich so
weit ich lag falsch und ich brauchte
noch eine neue matratze bevor ich
schlafen gehe verrate ich euch jetzt
erst mal einen rabattcode der lautet
nämlich alex wie ganz einfach und damit
bekommt ihr unter fünf prozent auf alle
gerade laufenden rabattaktionen von emma
matratze das gute ist dieser rabatt code
verfällt auch schnell also ihr könnt
euch das ganze ruhig überlegen ihr habt
mich sechs monate zeit ganz österreich
deutschland schweiz also dach region ist
das ganze möglich liegt übrigens gerade
auf der ma 25 hybrid matratze ich würde
wirklich sagen ich glaube das ist schon
eines der top modellen die ihr gerade
bei emma kaufen könnt ihr müsst euch das
so vorstellen ich bin gerne ein bild an
die matratze ist quasi in verschiedene
schichten aufgeteilt und was man
wirklich merkt die matratze ist klima
aktiver und ja wirklich sehr sehr soft
also ich lag noch nie auf sondern weiche
matratze es ist wirklich wählen fünf
sterne hotel und vor allem nach meinem
anstrengen urlaub fühle ich das jetzt
sehr hoch und das keine sorgen wir das
licht ausmachen bitte man warum habe ich
kein kamera der punkt der mich
persönlich am meisten überzeugen würde
ihr habt 100 tage einen schlaftest also
wenns euch der name gefällt können dass
dinge zurückstellen dazu gibt es
natürlich kostenlosen versand und ihr
habt 10 jahre garantie auf den matratzen
kern das erste licht ist schon aus ich
jetzt schlafen leute denken meint alex
wie und checkte mal die matratzen aus
oder auch hier die kissen bezahlt habe
ich beim letzten auf 200 euro und wo hat
mir auch gesagt alex ist kann aber auch
mal sein dass es wirklich ort ist und
man halt wirklich dann pech hatten
verstanden sich jedoch oder ist dass
kristalle züchten also ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen erster eindruck ist jetzt
erstmal sehr enttäuschen beim anderen
war es deutlich besser aber vielleicht
ist ja hier in diesem kartons trotzdem
was krasses drin man weiß ja nicht kann
ja auch sein dass allein dieses paket
schon 200 euro wert ist und dann ist ja
alles wieder gut was haben wir hier
einen du in one electric truma von touch
beauty nie gehört damit können wir auch
gut anfangen backlit led panel leid ach
so okay es ist ein licht für eine ahnung
hat iphone liest screen wie vor ins tor
das ist dass irgend so ein china handy
display ist allerdings schon leicht
gesplittet hier unten kann man im müll
schmeißen
123456 mal led lights leute vorsichtig
ich habe wirklich das gefühl das einst
von den dingern einfach 60 euro kostet
wo man das wäre ja echt bild das hier
sind lahm ich glaube die sind fürs
badezimmer oder küche oder was auch
immer also ganz normale lampen und ich
glaube ja auch keinen scheiß erzählen
lampen sind fairerweise zugeben gar
nicht mein spezialgebiet und hier
kosteten set von sechs lampen 60 euro
das heißt wir haben hier ja sechs lampen
und das kostet dann 60 euro meinetwegen
gut kann man jetzt schon mal mit
arbeiten ansonsten ich sehe wirklich
dass ich sehe hier wirklich ein paar
große kartons und darunter verbirgt sich
eigentlich nur müll aber dass hier was
ist es das ist schwer und schwerst
meistens sogar ganz husec incubator ach
so für das ja auch interessant ich habe
zwar noch nie davon gehört aber wir
googeln es jetzt einfach mal man kann
auf jeden fall rein legen gut maschine
wtf ach so ist das dann für die
landwirtschaft incubator fully
automatisch löschen dann irgendwann
wirklich münchen raus die gar nur mein
gott eine taube auf 18 tage zu schlüpfen
und eine ente 28 wusste ich nicht wieder
was gelernt und hier spielen dann kleine
kinder mit den frisch geschlüpften
münchen ich verstehe jetzt die
verwendung da für mich keinen plan aber
das bringt 100 euro perfekt aber marie
lockt also ich mache mir jetzt ein
bisschen gedanken dazu an sich ist
sicherlich nur für die landwirtschaft
oder weil wer schenkt so was ja nicht
meinen kindern damit die zuhause münchen
züchten
ok und wenn wir schon mal dabei sind
haben wir hier eine flur lampe und da
bin ich mir auch relativ sicher dass
dinge gar nicht mehr günstig aber es
könnte natürlich auch perfekt sein aber
ich muss sagen die sachen die ich beim o
kaufe ich glaub ich kann mich nicht
daran erinnern dass damals viel defekt
war leute ich kann es euch immer zeigen
ist auch alles noch schön verpackt es
gibt eigentlich wirklich gut aus auch
hier fernbedienung frisch eingepackt
kann man via fernbedienung schumacher
interessant ich tippe auf 150 euro habe
ich mich leider etwas überschätzt kostet
70 aber immerhin eine ahnung ist er
trotzdem gut dann schauen wir mal was
wir hier noch zu haben vor allem die
guten sachen eben raus und den müll dass
sich darin schon wieder ein
blutdruckmessgerät hey die sind wirklich
an scheint also ich weiß nicht warum
aber in fast jedem amazon nur amazon
retouren paket sind diese
blutdruckmessgeräte apam intelligent ich
hab' ich hab den trip im radio in kuchen
also der erste eindruck hat mich doch
ein bisschen getäuscht die wohl die
audio das sieht auch gar nicht nach so
einen schrott modell aus haben wir uns
das ding noch mal an made in boston aha
alles noch top verpackt das ding wird
funktionieren ich würde dann geschaut
mehr leute ich will es ungern da
rausholen ich habe mal kurz nach was das
kostet hahaha mein gott damit habe ich
nicht gerechnet aber das ding kostet
einfach 350 euro hier leute gibts ja mir
genau dieses modell boom könnt ihr sehen
ich habe schon gedacht sagt irgendwie
sieht das anders aus er sieht nicht
auszusagen billig china amazon apple
produkt die wohl die audio white grey
und es ist ja absolut und im neuen
zustand also wenn ich das verkaufen
würde würde ich da auf jeden fall schon
hat euro für einkommens 11 da unten ist
noch was krasses heftig das täuscht
manchmal auch wirklich hier haben wir
einen
keramik lampe ist nicht spannend ist
halt eine lampe keine ahnung 20 euro
oder so meinetwegen heute dann haben wir
hier noch eines das der dms aus zitrus
presse ja ja also sowas vielleicht mal
für meine wohnung soll ja sehr gesund
sein ich habe mir früher mal in köln
gewohnt hat gegenüber hat mir seinen
hits da habe ich mir morgen zu einem
schönen o saft gepresst alter und dies
auch nice sowas ist bestimmt gar nicht
mehr so günstig oder elektronische ist
die elektronisch ich glaube schon 40
euro 50 euro kostet auf sowas und auf 1a
zustand die nehme ich einfach mal mit
nach hause das hatten wir hier noch mal
auch wieder eine lampe also ist wirklich
zum großen teil seine lampen retouren
box ok weitergeht national geographic
professional rock tumblr absolut keine
ahnung dass es ist vielleicht so ja
kann man damit also mein erster gedanke
damit kann man wahrscheinlich deine
zerstören macht das sinn aber national
geographic ist ja auch schon so einen
namen das kennt man ja mir scheint
irgendwie so als würde etwas fehlen und
zwar dieses ding rock tumblr alter
kostet einfach auf 115 euro aber da
fehlt halt was wird das jetzt gerne mal
testen was das genau kann aber wie
gesagt dieses aufsatz dingen fehlt und
somit hat sich das leider erledigt okay
eigentlich haben wir nur noch müll drin
hier sind noch zwei oder drei
überwachungskameras hier haben wir eine
okay das ist keine überwachungskamera
das ist eine lichterkette in hirschhorn
die haben wir auch gleich noch mal keine
ahnung jetzt so zu weihnachten geht das
ja vielleicht eine fernbedienung hatte
ich auch noch nie drin das wäre
natürlich nice wenn dazu auch der
passende fernseh parat wäre apropos
fernseher ich habe ja einige fernseher
bestellt stück glaube ich insgesamt für
nur 300 euro auf das projekt bin ich
auch richtig hype und gespannt und dann
haben wir noch lampen und eine sache
hatten wir hier ja noch die ich dachte
wer ganz nice ist es ja auch nur eine
lampe ist es dann nämlich auf den ersten
blick auch so aus wie das radio wenn mal
18 watt led wand leuchtet nachts gibt es
für 40 euro bei kaufland ein rasierer
der leider schon ausgepackt ist aber
funktioniert da sind ja haare dran egal
ich filme euch mal einfach nochmal hier
so ein bisschen rein also so sieht das
aus das ist jetzt wirklich alles nur
noch schrott halter ist ja ein riesen
taschenrechner guck mal habt ihr schon
mal sagen wo es zum taschenrechner
gesehen jetzt auch noch smart watch hier
sind alles auch irgendwelche komischen
lampen cola garten leute ich war dann
jetzt am ende doch noch sehr positiv
überrascht von den ganzen sachen hat
sich dann letztendlich doch her gelohnt
als ich dachte also der erste einblick
war so ach du scheiße was wir das denn
ich würde sogar fast sagen also wir
haben jetzt elf die 1000 euro uvp sie
drin natürlich hat man dass da nicht
rausholen aber wenn ich das jetzt alles
verkaufen würde würde ich denke ich
schon ein vernünftiges geschäft machen
quer mittlerweile immer öfter gefragt
was ich so mit den ganzen einzelnen
sachen mache also oftmals verschenke ich
sachen manchmal verkaufe ich sachen auch
einzeln weiter und manchmal verstehe ich
so paketweise das ganze auch einfach
über ebay weiter weil ich ja wieder
platz schaffen muss das ist halt immer
so vor unterschiedlich also ich habe
keinen eigenen shop mehr wo ihr das
alles finden können das einzige was ich
jetzt habe ist so ein eigener
amazon-shop den kann ich euch hier gern
mal kurz ein wenden da werde ich immer
so ein paar sachen rein da nicht hier
auch in meinen videos auspacken check
das game ab ansonsten vielen dank fürs
zuschauen wir sehen uns in ein paar
tagen jetzt das video drei leute
abonnieren favorisieren daumen nach oben
teilen kommentieren